attention ladies and gentlemen this is
your pilot speaking uh we're approaching
30,000 they thought I'd do a little rap
for you up here and get ready for it
hey everyone my name is Matt bellezza
and this is whine about it a weekly
video series where I get drunk at my
desk and complain about stuff on this
week's episode the worst types of people
who take airplanes with me I know
everyone's got their airplane stories
alright but this is my struggle let's
drink
alright first of all there's always that
one bloated genital wart who thinks it's
acceptable to recline their damn seat
ten seconds and every damn flight
fitting me into an airplane seat is like
trying to fit a walrus into one of them
paddle boats it's difficult enough then
you gotta come in and make it worse by
pushing your seat all the way back for
what an extra little two inches of
comfort that's all you get I should have
figured is any person who reclines their
seat on an airplane is exactly the kind
of person who deserves joy from two
inches of comfort you get it you get it
like a penis though there's those people
who get on an airplane and try to fight
me over my damn armrest
excuse me sir I didn't choose to sit
next to your heaping mound of in
existence fate brought us together but
so help me God I will use my to
moisturize elbows now jab you right in
the windpipe last time I checked we were
both on a flight to Acapulco we weren't
on a flight to WWE elbow mania but I'll
turn it into that get to that point sir
because I have two elbows right here I'm
not afraid to use them next people who
bring food from home do you think I
wouldn't bring my Cornish game hens
home if I could I need the hell out of
those Cornish game hens I finished
before the plaintiff it took off that's
how good my Cornish game hens are
they're so good
but I've got a monster you on the other
hand had the damn nerve to bring a
plastic baggie full of cream of shrimp
soup you're just sucking it up with a
straw right your little plane seat an
airplane is done the dumpster behind a
Burger King I know that that's where
you're used to because you're a piece of
garbage you can't just eat whatever you
want here you can't just have it your
way
you eat your cream of shrimp soup in the
gutter like God intended then there's
always that person who thinks it's fun
to complain it out
airport security like there's some kind
of special snowflake and everybody else
doesn't have to do everything that they
got to do you're not special just
because um but I won't get one free
shoes from Payless that you don't want
to take off your [ __ ] feet we're all
here doing the same thing sir so take
off your damn shoes pull out your damn
laptop and get it in line your sniveling
ass weasel next there's all those people
who know they should check their bags
Thanks still trying to sneak it onto the
airplanes even though it's too big you
think this plane is just gonna be
magically big enough to fit all your
damn [ __ ] I didn't squeeze all my
lotions into tiny little bottles because
it's fun I did it cuz them's the rules
so why don't you just put your luggages
if the little luggages rollercoaster
like everybody else and get on the damn
plane and shut your damn mouth next
there's all those people who try to
judge you forget it drunk on the
airplane what a grown man can't enjoy
nice adult bambridge why soaring through
the sky like a majestic Falcon flying is
unnatural if you're gonna stick me in a
metal tube and watch me through the damn
sky i'ma need a damn drink
okay leathers those people who take a
big old [ __ ] right in the airplane
you're just pooping into a little plain
bucket so we have to carry with us all
the way to where we're going we just
have to fly with your poo you turn this
plane into a flying outhouse like that
scene from that movie where Dorothy so I
saw house two the wizard except with way
more poop then finally there's always
those people who look perfect every time
they get off an airplane here your
perfect airplane hair you piece of [ __ ]
everybody should get off an airplane
look like they just survived a fist
fight with a swamp monster middle of a
hurricane that's what I look like
that's why I look like alright everybody
thank you for watching this week as
always you can find our videos I really
got a whineaboutit.tumblr.com my page
which is facebook.com/buzzfeedmatt and
find our videos on youtube.com slash
BuzzFeed video if you want and that's it
that's everything that's a little bit
Oh shoes uh-uh I spent $30 at Payless if
I don't want to take off my shoes so
what if they get dirty just take off
your damn shoes I'm sick of it